today is book launch day for Chris
Hogan's new book every day
millionaires that's right how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth and
how you can - if you haven't heard the
story
our Ramsey solutions and Chris Hogan
he's one of our Ramsey personalities
came together we had an outside research
firm and we completed the largest study
of millionaires ever done in North
America over 10,000 of them about half
of them were people who knew of me and
knew of this show and knew of the things
we teach about half up never heard of me
and oddly enough the statistical
differences in those two groups was
almost zero so we thought there might be
some differences but there weren't
basically the people that knew me we're
doing the same stuff that the people
didn't know me we're doing to become
millionaires because it is now believed
in America that you can't get ahead by
some of you that you're stuck and the
only way to get it only way become
wealthy is to inherit it and there are
people that say that every single day
and well the largest study ever done
airtight research of millionaires says
that you're wrong you're wrong you're
wrong
79 percent of millionaires that we
studied receives zero inheritance five
percent received less than $100,000 and
most of the people that we did receive
an inheritance beyond that received it
after they were already millionaires so
at least 84 percent somewhere probably
closer to 90 percent of millionaires did
not become millionaires because of
inherited money that is simply a lie we
have the largest study ever done with
airtight research it's simply a lie well
you have to be people of privilege know
every color every background every sex
every region had about the same
incidence of millionaires about the same
not exactly but about the same well you
have to go to a prestigious school
that's how you become successful
not according to this study if you line
up ten millionaires seven of them went
to public colleges state colleges one of
them went to a community college one of
them didn't go to college and one of
them went to a prestigious school so
that data says a prestigious school does
not cause you to be successful
it must be other things financially
successful anyway if you want to be a
millionaire a Millionaire is someone
with a million dollar net worth and so
Ivy League schools is not it inheriting
it is not it so what is it eighty
percent of the millionaires see these
statistics are all 80 and 90 percent
numbers you don't find statistical
analysis and research that is like that
most the time it's 57 percent and we
call it well over half you know this is
80 freaking percent of these
millionaires use their 401k and they
paid off their home in an average of ten
point two years and so we find someone
with a million-two net worth with a
$500,000 paid for house and 700 thousand
dollars in their 401k and there may even
be in there how they do that they invest
it over time well stock market rates of
return have made them rich you can say
what you want about the stock market you
can say what you say want to say about
mutual funds you can say what you want
to say about the fees and the 401ks and
you can go on and on and on and on and
on about your freakin theories but
they're your theories our mythology in
actual fact the people that become
millionaires the first stage of wealth
the first million to five million
dollars of net worth comes from
investing in their 401k and good growth
stock mutual funds over 15 to 20 years
plus and paying off their home in ten
point two years oh and by the way they
don't use any debt they hate that
haven't carried consumer debt in an
average of twenty years no car payments
no credit card debt they don't carry
that they might have had a little debt
early in their misspent youth but they
got rid of it and they figured out that
debt was a robber so it sounds a lot
like the stuff we've been teaching
Patrick who's a millionaire says I don't
invest in single stocks my investing has
been in 401 k's roth iras and mutual
funds and index funds Joe or Jose says
I'm he's a millionaire says I Drive a
ten-year-old Mazda cx-9 there's almost
two or thousand miles on end of all the
cars we purchased in the past ten years
all have been used cars and we purchase
them in cash rich says who's a
millionaire I didn't attend an Ivy
League school as far as I got was two
years in Community College and I owe a
lot of that to my folks they instilled
in me to save save save
I don't know money to anyone and I think
the biggest part is having a plan of
sticking the plan budgeting and smart
investing here's the thing 97% of the
millionaires we interview that's all of
them okay 97% that's all of them when
asked the question are you in control of
your own destiny
said yes 54% of the general public said
yes so if you are one of those people
who believes you're not in control of
your destiny the data points tell us
that you're probably not going to be in
control of your destiny you're probably
not going to be in everyday millionaire
that's what the data tells us belief and
acting on the belief that it can be done
and you have to take the hard steps to
cause it to happen then I'm not going to
get a good crop of corn if I don't plant
some freakin corn that you're gonna reap
what you sow we live in a
cause-and-effect world that the American
Dream isn't that the belief of these
things are what caused you to be an
everyday millionaire that's what Chris
Hogan concluded in this book you want to
read all the statistics the book is on
sale now we predict that this time next
week we will be announcing eight number
one bestseller
I don't think interesting question we've
sold so many of them in presale it's
unbelievable so he's in New York today
he just
finished up at Fox and Friends we'll
talk to him after the break and then
we'll get to some of your calls but this
is important information the you know
the my friend Tom Stanley did the book
millionaire next door
25 years ago and came to a lot of the
same conclusions they only studied 750
people and one of the big arguments by
the detractors was was that the sample
size wasn't large enough now those of
you that know something about statistics
know that Tom's sample size was large
enough for it to be conclusive but if
you don't know anything about statistics
meaning you never took one of those
classes then you don't know that so just
in case as a PR maneuver we thought we
want to do 10x what Tom did 25 years ago
we need at least 7,500 well we didn't
stop we took it all the way to ten
thousand millionaires that we studied
and the conclusions are in the book
everyday millionaires how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth and
how you can - my number one best-selling
author Chris Hogan
[Music]